si on a adoré faire à logbaba et ce soit
chez ma bague qui restera pour moi un
des plus beaux souvenirs télé même si
c'était pendant une période très très
difficile voilà en tout cas vous
accompagnez ça a été un bonheur pour moi
c'est ce qu'on disait créé crohn et on
espère que on le fera plus jamais un
bien entendu qu'on ne sera plus jamais
dans cette situation mais en tout cas on
a adoré vous vous accompagner dans ce
soir chez ba ba on a aussi eu plein de
gros invités de grosse rigolade c'est
vrai que notamment big le holy gad
elmaleh à m sila qui a été formidable
dazhou la juke j'aime elie semoun
gastambide frérot d'amour guerre franck
qui a fait 20 millions de vues 1 sur
valider bouder chantal ladesou tout le
monde et je voulais qu'on voie quelques
moments de ce qu'on a appelé la grande
charia depuis ce que ce sera maintenant
un prime sur s'est vite à la rentrée
c'était le 1er avril pour les 10 ans de
tpm paix et on a tout ce qui fait quand
on a tous charrier gad elmaleh qui était
en train de faire du vélo d'appartement
pendant toute l'émission
il voulait absolument faire son vélo et
participer à l'émission je voudrais dire
gad il aussi c'est vraiment un ami très
très très très proches
je laime fort et je vais vous dire un
truc sur gad elmaleh c'est le seul mec
qui est sûr de son talent palais il fait
encore des compliments aux autres je
vous jure que c'est vrai moi il m'a
laissé un message à semaine dernière
concernant l'émission
il m'a dit franchement c'est
exceptionnel ce que vous faites voilà
aiguades voilà c'est un des seuls dans
le métier qui fait encore des
compliments aux autres etc
voilà c'est un mec s'en fout de la
réussite des autres au contraire il aime
quand les gens réussissent il est
heureux pour reese et c'est pour ça
qu'il est toujours au dessus et c'est
toujours le numéro moins regardé le gala
entre héros l'add on dirait thomas
pesquet gains
la laurent jalabert ya laurent jalabert
et tu vois ta put alors que tu pédales
est arrivé encore ya des indications
pour toi vas-y ça fait dix ans tu fais
du sport c'est quand que ça se voit gad
elmaleh alors voilà un plateau
exceptionnel et je vous savez cette
émission on la fera en vrai avec ces
mêmes invités en septembre ou en octobre
je vous dis c'est sûr on en train de
travailler dessus ça s'appellera la
grande charia je vous remercie à m sila
parce que je vais travailler aussi avec
lui avec son frère ou et avec son frère
parce que c'est ahmed aussi avec qui on
a eu l'idée est qu'à combes et bien sûr
on en train de travailler dessus et on
sera là même bande je vous dis et ça va
balancer de ouf